it's just past 15 GMT and we start in
Pakistan where authorities say they will
follow court orders and arrest former
prime minister Imran Khan for failing to
show up in court on Monday well hundreds
of protesters are outside his residence
in Lahore and have fought with police
Security Forces fired tear gas and water
cannon to disperse the crowds but the
supporters are staying put Pakistan's
interior Minister has promised to arrest
Khan and take him to court by the end of
the day Khan is facing dozens of charges
including corruption
police has arrived at my residence to
arrest me and they think if I will be
arrested and imprisoned then the nation
will sleep but you all should prove them
wrong you have to prove you're a living
nation and the followers of prophet
Muhammad you have to fight for your
right and for the real Freedom you have
to come out and have to struggle I'm
fighting your fight I have struggled all
my life and will continue to fight but
if they put me behind bars or kill me
then you have to prove that without me
this nation will struggle for freedom
well let's go to our correspondent Kamal
hither he is joining us live from
Islamabad the determined determined as
ever former leader Imran Khan speaking
they come out but we're hearing that
special paramilitary forces meanwhile
have been ordered to his house this is
also a determined government to arrest
the former prime minister
indeed the government has made no secret
of the fact the country's interior
Minister now saying that he will be
arrested it is now imminent and we have
been getting some reports that it may
have already taken place but we cannot
confirm that yet now earlier in the day
the police came in in strength they
brought in water cannons they brought in
tear gas they were scuffles with Imran
Khan supporters the interior Minister
then ordered the paramilitary forces to
beef up the police one of the police
officers who had gone to arrest Imran
Khan from Islamabad was said to have
been injured as a result of the stone
throwing by the protesters and after
that of the direct the deputy
Inspector General of police was given
the task of arresting Imran Khan they
have now put a Siege around this house
Imran Khan supporters of course that
there and Imran Khan himself has now
announced a six-member emergency
Committee of the leadership which will
run the party Affairs in his absence in
case he's arrested the likelihood of
that being being very high now we are
also finding out that there's been a
strong reaction
in the southern Port City of Karachi
they have been protest and other cities
of the Punjab a main highway from German
to quetta this is one of the roads that
links onwards to Afghanistan has been
blocked by protesters and also protests
now taking place near Islamabad and even
in the Twin City of Raul Pindi which is
just a few kilometers from here so
indeed a strong reaction the government
showing its determination that he that
it will arrest Imran Khan however the
charges against them and it should not
be forgotten that there are 77 cases
that have been brought against Imran
Khan the government in power has tried
every trick in the book to try to nail
him the higher courts of course have
given him relief because of the
frivolous charges many uh jurists and
legal experts believe that those charges
will not hold in a court of law and of
course now supporters coming out and the
situation indeed quite tense and really
interesting that the protests and taking
place in places other than Lahore now
you mentioned the many charges that he's
facing but his arrest the attempt to
arrest him is over failing to show up to
court in one particular case isn't it
Kamal can you explain what that is
uh yes that particular case
pertains to what is locally known as the
toshana the toshana is a state
repository every time a foreign head of
state comes to Pakistan or if Pakistani
heads of state go overseas they receive
expensive gifts these are then I was put
in a repository which is known as the
toshokana Imran Khan was accused of
taking one of the watches from that
doshakana although he made a rule that
it would be that he raised the price on
it to 50 percent of the value of the
goods and he had bought a watch which
was presented by the Saudi Crown Prince
he then sold that and recently a list
came out which showed all the
benefactors of the state gives former
prime minister Nawaz Sharif received
several gifts which he took for himself
without paying the money many other
politicians seniors bureaucrats are also
involved in taking those expensive gifts
at a pittance uh when it should be
deposited in the straight State Treasury
so the charges of course seem to be
based on political Vendetta according to
many political experts say the people of
course believe that Imran Khan has
emerged as the most popular political
leader in the country that the
government is looking for an excuse to
delay the elections and are using these
tactics in order to pressurize them that
is Kamal Hatha joining us with a very
latest live in Islamabad thank you for
that command
well let's get more on this we're joined
Now by Aretha Noor political analyst and
columnist for the Dawn News website and
she's joining us on Skype from Islamabad
thank you very much for your time so
police breaking up a gathering of Khan
supporters we saw last week Banning
large Gatherings didn't deter people
from congregating outside Mr Khan's home
today is the government action against
Imran Khan doing anything to deter
support or is it in fact bolstering it
um I think the government is uh perhaps
uh using this in a way to also keep uh
Imran Khan who is obviously a very
popular leader at the moment from
focusing on the election uh too much uh
because he's constantly as your
correspondent just pointed out he is
constantly being called to the various
courts and there's there are these
constant fears over his arrest so what
uh you know the courts are issuing
arrest warrants so to some extent of
course uh you know the government does
or want to arrest him they do want to uh
you know be able to control his
movements but it is also a way of trying
to keep him distracted and this is not
the first time this tactic has been used
if you look at Pakistan's history you
will see this at work time and again
that every time there is leader who's at
loggerheads or you know on a crash
course so um with the establishment
there are lots of cases against him and
the idea also is to keep them impairing
busy with their Court appearances which
then
for other activities so does that give
us an idea then of what you make of the
charges against Imran Khan he and legal
experts say they're frivolous do you
agree
foreign
I suppose it could be said in a way that
you know especially in Pakistan again
this is the history that when you do
have uh such charges against uh
political leaders at a certain time in
their careers they are what we call
politically motivated cases even if
there is some to them the fact that they
have been initiated is due to politics
and whenever they do end it is also due
to the politics rather than the Merit of
the case itself and it's not just uh
political cases or rather legal cases
that politicians in Pakistan are used to
facing it Khan has survived an
assassination attempt on his life and he
keeps warning that there is a threat to
his life and this is a country that's
also no stranger to political leaders
being killed is he being provided
adequate security
this is a difficult question with
because it's a very simple objective
view of what security can be or should
be as you yourself said that you know
Pakistan as a political history is full
of violent events and we very recently
at least in our political memory of Las
Vegas
an assassination attack and Imran Khan
himself has also been targeted once and
he still claims that he hasn't recovered
fully from that attack so
um you know security is a difficult
thing to provide in Pakistan to anyone
or any institution as you can see we're
constantly
witnessing a terrorist attacks these
days and then um obviously this is also
a question of how do you provide uh
security to a political leader at the
time on a front end of an election when
his um you know schedule is perhaps full
of interaction with the people yeah
election campaigns Pakistan tend to be
in very you know the kind of
environment in which they take place
security is not very easy to ensure no
and of course he's saying that he's not
actually being allowed to hold any
election or campaign rallies we'll have
to leave it there for now thank you very
much for your insights on this we do
appreciate it that is Eddie for New Life
for Us in Islamabad thank you